is crazy there's cassie stanley with the
bucket
stanley played with the pacers last year
started this year with detroit but was
waived and then resigned again they got
six guys from the g league in the last
six days
quickly trying to draw some contact
so he will head right back to the line
david cervetis
picks up his first
oh
i love that
picky lee what was uh
that reminds me of a couple of years ago
it was last year reggie bullock he had
one number on the front one number on
the back a different number on the back
that's right
there's a lot going on in that locker
room
everyone's trying to stay safe stay
healthy
oh that's funny well you you look at and
this was the same thing last year the
medical staff the training staff the
equipment staff because so much is going
on on a daily basis
in terms of additional responsibilities
in many cases they're overwhelmed with
the amount of extra stuff they have to
do and also if quick he's off to a good
start i wouldn't change that jersey you
know if someone notices keep that thing
on it's good luck you guys are awesome
you're all so superstitious professional
athletes as gibson grabs the rebound oh
i guarantee if he continues to have a
good first half he's not changing that
jersey in the second
i'm sure they the way zerbiakis spelled
they had to have misspelled numerous
times during your career they did my
rookier yes